welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar exploring tools
for regulatory compliance in the
shifting sands of the cannabis industry
it is presented by Ezra prior applied
market specialist at high Dolf North
America he is also a founding member of
the American Chemical Society cannabis
chemistry subdivision my name is Judy
O'Rourke and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots laberd's is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now about further ado please
join me in welcoming Ezra prior I will
now turn the presentation over to him
thank you so much for that wonderful
introduction Judy and as she mentioned
my name is Ezra Pryor I'm applied market
specialist with hot off north america
and founding member of the American
Chemical Society's cannabis chemistry
subdivision and today I'm going to talk
to you about tools that you can use to
support your own regulatory compliance
in the cannabis industry so I'm just
gonna give you a quick overview and let
you know what we're gonna be talking
about today compliance is a challenge
certainly it is a complex challenge and
it can be unclear what rules we need to
follow and when
those rules change and what we need to
do if we're not following those rules to
then become compliant right
non-compliance is both dangerous and
costly so we can see issues along the
lines of accidents happening because
you're not in compliance and those
compliance rules are there to keep us
safe we can see fines we can see loss of
license things like that so it's
certainly certainly a significant issue
and the good thing is that you're not
alone there's a lot of resources that
are available that can help us be
successful in this space so some of
these solutions would include
Environmental Health and Safety officers
or compliance officers so these are
going to be full-time staff within your
facility that can help you address some
of these challenges a consultant so
somebody from a third party an outside
company that can give you advice on how
to better follow those those issues all
those rules another would be nonprofit
certifications so there are institutions
which are nonprofits and are willing to
come to you with a set of standards and
evaluate you for your ability to address
to meet those standards and then you
know provided you can live up to those
standards then you can you can be
certified with that company so that can
be an asset for your doing business with
customers or with other businesses and
lastly we have the software support
solutions and what's really interesting
about these software support solutions
is that they operate with all of the
previous three solutions or on their own
so you can use that software tool to
make your environment the health and
safety officer more effective to help
that consultant be more effectively
using their time work to help that
nonprofit certification better evaluate
you for compliance so one of the
problems around compliance is that it's
a moving target so we're gonna see
changes in that legal landscape right
when when laws change so does compliance
and so it's going to be a challenge to
understand what you need to do to stay
compliant sometimes we have medical
recreational or hemp laws that are
completely distinct from each other and
so what your facility is is going to
have an effect on on what you need to do
to be compliant and you may have a
facility that had did those multiple
things right sometimes we have
provisional regulations so in California
for example we had about a year of
regulations that were in place for just
that year while they were working on the
larger regulations so that's difficult
because you need to be compliant with
those provisional regulations and then
you need to be ready to be compliant
with those permanent regulations revised
regulations so we see states where their
regulations were certainly not ideal and
they realize that and then they change
them so you've got to be able to be
aware of what those those regulations
are as they change because you'll be
response with them you know I have an
ongoing basis and then some places have
multi-state facilities which means
having multiple sets of regulations in
order to be compliant and so that can be
a real big challenge hopefully someday
we'll have regulations that are the same
across state lines but it's not what
we're doing that's not where we're at
right now so just to give you a sense of
you know what is the state of compliance
how how are people doing and the state
of Oregon had a particularly poor
reputation for being in compliance
number one there they didn't have a
whole lot of oversight they didn't
they're the regulatory body was not
prepared to really oversee all of these
facilities they just made the law such
that people could get started and they
got started but two-degree - it
that are following the rules was was
pretty limited so 27 percent were found
to have deficiencies and 10 percent were
at risk of closure so those deficiencies
were so significant that it actually
merited closing down the facility and
it's important to realize that this is
only 10 percent of those facilities that
were open in Oregon so safety issues
compliance is not arbitrary so
oftentimes when we see regulatory
compliance rules they apply to things
that can keep us from endangering
environmental health endangering our
worker safety health and endangering a
consumer health right so safety issues
are something that we can avoid by being
in compliance so let's take a look at a
few of these issues that we discovered
on a laboratory audit so this is where I
like to play an audience participation
game but given the format of today
that's not really feasible so we're just
gonna kind of go through them so we've
got three issues pictured here and the
first issue on the left is an obscured
exit I'm sorry an obstructed exit so we
have boxes that have been placed in
front of the door and that's not a good
place for storage because if there's a
fire if there's an accident and some
people have to rush out of that facility
then they're gonna be tripping over
these boxes and then tripping over each
other and potentially not making it out
so that's a huge issue to be aware of
the other issue in the middle is that
there's a extension cord that's running
on the floor and under the door so
number one that extension cord should
not be permanently installed extension
cords are for temporary use number two
is a tripping hazard because it's
running across the doorway and number
three that's gonna that's gonna wear
down over time because the doors is
rubbing against it constantly right
lastly the one I always ask people to
guess and nobody ever can is that the
fire extinguisher is is obscures hidden
right the fire extinguisher is hiding
behind those traffic signs on the bottom
right so that was a huge issue because
if there's a fire if there's next than
where you need a fire extinguisher you
want to be able to find that you know
you don't want to have to be stumbling
around looking for it so those are three
significant issues this one here is a
little less obvious so this is a
flammables cabinet so this applies more
to laboratories so all of the brown
bottles on top are solvents right so
methanol ethanol asked to and things
like that and they're gonna be extremely
flammable so that's why they're in this
cabinet a lot of times people use these
flammable cabinets to store other
chemicals even though it's not
appropriate so it would be appropriate
to store acids along with your
flammables however when you include a
base in with your acid then you have a
serious issue because that reaction is
going to be exothermic which means that
it's going to produce heat and when you
produce a lot of heat in the same
container as a whole bunch of flammable
solvents you could have yourself a
serious chemical fire so and if you're
if you're keeping score here it's that
little plastic bottle down in the bottom
that the arrow is pointing to that is
sodium hydroxide in pellet form and that
clear bottle to the right of it would be
concentrated hydrochloric acid so the
two of those mixed together is going to
make a really strong reaction and this
is a little bit of levity but it's also
[Music]
it's also an important issue so it's him
it's critical that we don't just think
about safety or talk about safety it's
important that we find a way to make an
action plan so we can move forward and
correct those is
and really avoid some safety risks
because if we can talk about it and you
know if we're not taking any action it's
not doing any good and I think of a lot
of times that's a risk that we take
because it's such a challenging role
just to be able to establish that you
know what is that safety issue we spend
all this time evaluating what are these
safety issues that we neglected to
actually act on those things and
eliminate those issues so I'd love to
take a minute to talk about a laboratory
in California that was inspected by the
state OSHA so this was a real tragedy
this laboratory had several issues and
I'm only gonna highlight three of them
and and you can see just what kind of
fines were talking about so the first
issue is that they had blocked exits and
fire extinguishers so not unlike the
ones we saw in the first photograph now
this is going to cost that facility one
hundred and fifty six thousand seven
hundred and seventy two dollars now the
second issue was the fire extinguishers
were not maintained and that means
having your fire extinguishers inspected
on a regular basis and making sure that
their pressure is sufficient and
changing them out if they're if they're
losing pressure
so that cost this facility eighty seven
thousand two hundred and ninety seven
dollars now the last one is about a
hazardous communication plan right so
what happens if there's a chemical spill
what does your what your employees do
what if somebody gets a chemical burn
these are things that need to be in
writing so it's not enough if everybody
knows what to do everybody needs to know
what to do and it needs to be in writing
and this cost that company nearly a
quarter million dollars and
unfortunately this facility was not able
to stay open because of the magnitude of
their expenses the magnitude of their of
their fines so this is a huge issue and
you know if you've put a lot of time in
into getting a facility up and running I
mean of course you want to keep it so
you have to protect your license you
have to protect your workers sometimes
those are family members right so we
want to we want to make sure that you
know everybody's safe and that our
investment is safe so accidents can cost
a lot as well so the average workers
compensation settlement in 2015 it was
twenty one thousand eight hundred
dollars and that's just the average
certainly the potential is much higher
and as I mentioned sometimes we hire
people that we know our family members
and so of course we don't want them to
get hurt as well you could lose your
product so depending on the nature of
the accident you can lose huge
quantities of what you are distributing
and that can mean huge losses and if we
are dealing with slim margins then we
really are not in a position to be
throwing away product right you could
have a halt in production or
distribution sometimes an issue comes up
that's so significant that we need to
stop and we need to address that issue
before we continue and that means
stopping what you're doing and that
could be really losing a lot of money
recalls are huge liability if you find
that you're distributing contaminated
product you can deal with an average
direct cost of around ten million
dollars and the worst part of it is that
you can lose the trust of your customers
you can lose your loyalty your customer
loyalty because they feel betrayed and
that can go you know that's the indirect
cost and that can be really significant
so we want to avoid that certainly and
the last issue is that an accident can
cause a regulator to come in so you
could be you know lucky enough to never
be inspected but then you've got one
accident and all the sudden the fire
marshal wants to come and pick a visit
and that can be a huge issue so you can
you can have a lot of compliance issues
that
we never knew about and all of a sudden
you've got a lab accident and and now
they want to come look and if you're not
in compliance you could be dealing with
those fees and you could potentially be
losing your license yeah so loot loss of
license I mean ten percent of the
facilities in Oregon are at risk of
losing their license so it's not an
insignificant issue many states are just
rolling out regulatory oversight and so
it's been something we can get away with
in the past but it may not be moving
forward we could see more closures as
oversight ramps up so these these
departments are gonna live on fees and
so you know they're gonna they're gonna
try to do that they're gonna try to levy
a lot of fees so that they can fund
themselves and you know your eligibility
could be compromised so you could have a
license that you worked really hard to
get and if you get shut down if you lose
your license it may not be just as
simple to get it again so you know the
last thing that I want to call your
attention to is that there's oftentimes
law enforcement that wants to do
something in particular they want to
shut us down because they feel like
that's the right thing to do and so
they're looking for excuses to do that
this is a you know another little bit of
levity these guys got together and cut
down countless wild hemp plants right I
mean there is just wild hemp right but
they thought that was the right thing to
do and so they spent huge amounts of
energy and even though no there's nobody
breaking the law the plant can't be
arrested for you know dropping seeds of
planting itself so you want to give them
no excuses to to read your facility
right and tell me why they always seem
to look like they just like shot some
big game right
these plants did not defend themselves
so
the good news right there are solutions
for these issues there are resources to
help you succeed so the first is going
to be a compliance officer as I
mentioned previously and that's gonna be
somebody that works at your facility
full time and that's gonna be somebody
whose sole responsibility is for
establishing and maintaining compliance
the second solution is a consulting
service so there are a wide number of
consultants in the cannabis industry
that are willing to come in and help you
to address those issues I think you do
need to be careful because not every
consulting service can do everything so
there are also nonprofit certification
programs that can come and present the
set of standards to you and help you
need those standards so that you would
be prepared for perhaps federal
oversight as it as it comes and lastly
there's the self audit software so what
I really like about this self audit
software is that it's compatible with
all three solutions or it can stand
alone so we'll come back to all four of
these solutions so first off your
compliance officer and so again this is
a full-time employee they may lead a
team oftentimes compliance officers
you're gonna have direct supervision
over a number of people so that they can
address those issues in a timely manner
especially with large facilities the
average income for a facility I'm sorry
for a compliance officer or
Environmental Health and Safety Officer
is going to be around seventy one
thousand eight hundred dollars per year
they are going to help you establish
compliance and they're gonna help you
maintain compliance I think it's a
common misconception that the tricky
part is establishing compliance and then
once you've done that your job is done
but it really isn't because again we've
got these shifting legal landscapes
we've got issues that crop up and you
know there's always room for
provements and maintaining compliance is
going to be just as much of a job as
establishing compliance was and then
lastly they're gonna interface with
outside auditors hopefully better than
the little cartoon here but they're
going to be available for your facility
to be audited right so if the fire
marshal or the cannabis Control Board
comes in and wants to inspect your
facility then they've got a person that
is prepared for that eventuality and
that that person can help the auditor
get through your facility and it you
know without issues help provide all
that necessary paperwork so that's a
really significant advantage nonprofit
certificate programs so there are a
number of facilities that will start
organizations that can help you
establish a certification so these are
not necessarily going to be compliance
so you have to look at what are they
certifying on right so there's the
Cannabis certification Council there's a
to LA and then there's patient-focused
certification and in all cases there's
probably going to be more examples than
I'm gonna pull up but in the interest of
time I'm just gonna kind of pick a few
and then drill down a little bit so the
candidates certification Council is
chiefly focused on organic and fairly
produced cannabis so they're a
non-profit and they're you know
interested in education and transparency
for the cannabis industry and they were
formed out of the ethical cannabis
Alliance in Portland and the organic
cannabis Association in Denver and so
you know if your goal is legal
compliance these guys are probably not
going to be the ones to go with but if
your goal is to have an organic product
you know these guys are going to
probably be able to help you up the next
solution I'll talk about is a to LA and
so they focus on independent and
internationally record
certifications they are laboratory
certification only so they're not going
to really be able to help you out with a
grow or a dispensary but they are gonna
help you get that laboratory up to stuff
in a way that's internationally
recognized oh and they work on ISO
certifications and just to give you a
little bit of information about you know
what kind of certifications can you
actually get from a to LA so this is the
list yeah so as you can see these are
these are all focused on laboratories
and particularly testing laboratories so
and our next our next solution is going
to be Americans for safe access patient
focused certification and this one is
really specific to the cannabis industry
and so they used the American herbal
pharmacopoeia FDA and EPA regulations in
order to establish the standards that
they'll present to you and and help you
meet so they offer certifications for
cultivation manufacturing distribution
and laboratory so this is really
probably going to be your best solution
in terms of getting certified
specifically for cannabis facilities so
consulting companies again there are a
wide number of consulting companies and
I'm only gonna touch on a few cannabis
advising partners canna advisor American
and consult cannabis consulting and rgl
I'm sorry RJ LG or RJ lead group so
cannabis advising Partners so these this
company focuses on licensing and growth
and compliance as well and they focus on
California so that's great if you live
in California if you don't live in
California then this is probably not the
solution for you they do have 20
years of California compliance
experience so that's definitely positive
and they also claim to mention be
managing 1,300 facilities so that's
certainly an advantage and they're also
focusing primarily on licensing so their
their main competencies gonna be in
helping people get licenses so maybe
they're not the best for compliance but
you'd really have to investigate further
so next I'll talk about canna advisor so
these guys to business development
staffing sourcing brand development
licensing applications startup
operations readiness growth and
optimization exit strategy and oh yeah
compliance so they do a lot and so I
would be concerned with you know to what
degree are they proficient in in
compliance if that's really your goal is
to be in compliance
you know how good are they at it and
again that's something where you're
gonna want to interface with them
directly or you know interact with some
of their previous customers to to get a
sense of that and so the less the next
one I'm going to look at is the American
cannabis consulting so again we've got
the laundry list of equipment
fulfillment designed and build out hemp
services cultivation cube regulatory
compliance operations management
branding and marketing and oh yeah now
they're in all 50 states and canada so
that last statement really gives me
pause because last I checked there were
around 30 states that had some medical
or recreational cannabis provisions in
the law so what are they doing in the
other twenty I don't know
so maybe that's a good question to ask
them so a last consulting solution that
I'll point you towards is the RJ Lee
group so these guys are primarily they
operate in multiple industries so
they're they have a lot of experience in
terms of addressing challenge
across different industries they offer
legislative services in addition to
consulting I'm sorry in additional to
compliance they offer laboratory
services in Pennsylvania and Washington
so they have the advantage of actually
being a laboratory so they're going to
be able to do testing and such whether
or not they can do testing on cannabis
is another question and something you
should ask them and again they provide
laboratory services and compliance
support and the interesting thing is
they'll work with those nonprofit
certification programs and help you come
up to speed with those programs so that
I think there's an interesting advantage
if that's the way you want to go so the
last thing I want to talk to you about
is audit Pro hbx so this is a software
solution for compliance in the cannabis
industry and I have to admit that I'm
biased here because this is a solution
that hide off North America offers so
audit pro HBx you can learn more at
audit procom it's easy to use it loads
on any iPad or cell phone or laptop and
what it will do is provide you with a
series of checklists that you can use to
inspect your own facility this fast
automatic report generation so if you
have a compliance officer they're
typically going to be working with a
huge stack of binders and doing paper
audits and this could take months and in
the end they still need to use that data
that they've collected to generate
reports and what's really useful about
this tool here is that the reports are
automatically generated so not only can
we take what might have taken months and
can be down to a week or even a couple
days now you can take that that data and
instantly transfer it into a report and
we'll take a look at that and those
reports could be really useful for
getting getting your higher-ups to
understand the value of complying
and what's at risk and allocating the
proper resources they can also be useful
for motivating your team that are
responsible for addressing these issues
and they're really good because you can
customize them in order to better make
your case it's a cloud-based data
storage so you don't have to worry about
your device being broken and losing your
your data that way that your data is all
gonna be stored in a remote server so
that you don't have to worry about you
know whether that stuff is secure or not
it is customizable we can put in any set
of requirements so you can take these
for example these nonprofit
certification programs you can take
their criteria and punch them into the
system and then that's going to be able
to you know help you become compliant
that way and these guys come from an
environmental health and safety
background so the audit profile and
safety and waste remediation long before
the software tool existed and they saw
that there was this need and so they
were able to address that and this audit
Pro software is not brand new instead
they've gotten nearly a decade of
experience in utilizing this product in
healthcare manufacturing education and
research so let's take a moment and just
kind of look at what we're actually
talking about right so I can talk about
it so I'm blue in the face but let's
let's take a look at it so the software
tool is going to give you a set of
yes-or-no questions that are broken down
and just subsets so first you know which
kind of a facility are we looking at are
we're looking at a cultivation retail
dispensary and then we're gonna be able
to look at specific issues like
packaging and labeling security still on
its so forth and then once we get down
to that we're gonna be able to actually
get to these checklists and these
yes-or-no questions are gonna be able to
be addressed
as you walk through your own facility
and inspect that facility and so you're
gonna be able to take a photograph make
a comment specific to your issue which
could be really useful because if you're
gonna communicate that issue to somebody
who's responsible for doing that job it
may not be clear what they need to do in
order to be you know taking care of that
for you so here's an example of a photo
they were supposed to be an alarm on the
door there's no alarm on that door and
you're able to just scribble onto it you
know no alarm and the other thing is
that when we're done so that's the front
end right that's those are the
checklists and that's what it looks like
when you are actually doing your survey
now after you've done your survey you
get a report automatically generated and
this is the most plain option for the
report these are line items but what's
really useful is you can look at
specifically what was the issue what is
the corrective action required
what's the regulation that applies to
this were there any photos what is it
gonna cost me and these are all
automatically generated and I don't know
if you guys have tried to read
regulations like cover to cover but it
is awful it's dry it's never-ending and
what's really useful here is you can
take an issue that you've discovered in
your laboratory without knowing the
regulation you've identified that issue
and then they'll give you a little blurb
about what in that regulation applies to
that issue
so as you're discovering issues in your
laboratory or other facility you can
learn about those regulations piece by
piece which i think is really cool
yeah so again that's that's the
corrective action and and what was the
issue and then lastly you can assign
these to people on your team so these
people are going to get an email that
looks that outlines all this information
and you're gonna be able to take that
and push it forward to them and you're
gonna be able to track that too so on
your own system let's say you've got
five people on your team you can assign
these to any of the five people and then
you're gonna get notifications when they
come back and tell you that it's done
right so that can be a really good tool
for increasing communication and making
sure things don't fall off your radar
right user there's a lot of things to
keep track of here and so if we can keep
them all on a on a spreadsheet and get
automatic updates as to you know when
they're being done then that's that's a
whole lot of load off your back right
and then lastly we've got graphic
reports so these are gonna talk about
you know how long were reports open
where issues open which facilities have
the most issues what was the most
expensive issue which facility has the
most expensive issues you know what
employee is handling their issues better
than others right so that's a tremendous
resource for not only informing yourself
about what those issues are and where
they are and who's taking care of them
and how much they might cost you but
they're also a tremendous resource for
making an argument to your boss or your
employees about what's important and
what we need to spend resources on right
because we all have limited resources so
not only do we help you execute these
things in a short period of time but we
also can help you identify where your
limited resources are most useful so I
think that's a really tremendous
opportunity and you know as I mentioned
before this works with all those
previous solutions so you can have an
Environmental Health and Safety Officer
who can utilize this product to better
do their job you can have a consultant
that uses this product to evaluate your
facility before they even fly out so
they know what they're walking into and
you can save yourself like a plane
ticket writing because usually you gotta
fly a consultant out and also you know
it can work with that third-party a
certification program because
you can input any criteria you'd like
into that system it's easy to use
anybody can just pick it up and have the
expertise of a seasoned auditor at their
fingertips its customizable you can you
can change the way your reports look you
can change the way when you could change
what's on the checklist you can add you
can add stuff it's is really flexible
tool it's got fast and automatic report
generation its cloud-based data storage
so it's all really secure and lastly
it's gonna improve your compliance and
improve your safety and reduce risk
automatically and the way that it's
gonna do this is by helping you identify
issues identify solutions to those
issues and then track your progress
through those issues being addressed so
as I mentioned in the beginning
compliance is a huge issue compliance is
hard but you're not alone
you've got a whole lot of tools
available to you that can help you
address these issues though the many
sources of support come as environmental
and Safety Officer or clients officer
nonprofit certification programs
consultants and my personal favorite
software tools so these are some of my
resources
I'm sorry references I'm gonna make this
presentation available as a PDF so if
you'd like to download it you certainly
welcome to and then lastly I'm just
gonna put my contact information up
because if there's anything I can do to
help you I'm happy to do it so feel free
to reach out and looking forward to
hearing from you
thank you very much thank you ever for
that informative presentation I would
also like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that this webcast will be available for
on
man viewing from June 28 2019 and as a
final reminder our speaker will follow
up with any questions you've submitted
via email that's all for now thank you
for joining us and we will see you next
time goodbye